un cadeau c'est pas toujours de l'argent
moi par exemple une présence par exemple
si tu me dis tiens pour Noël ce qu'on a
jamais fait on dit ensemble pour Noël
c'est gentil chez toi puisque ma journée
est morte le 12
[Rires]
mars même si tu dis à la maison c'est
vrai le 12 bien sûr
je peux attention je mets quoi dîner
bébé
je rigole pas je t'invite moi t'inquiète
pas tu t'es invité c'est bon à la maison
qu'est-ce que vous voulez quand votre
cadeau allez voilà lui il veut que je
l'invite toi c'est bon je m'occupe de
toi c'est bon toi je voudrais un massage
aux pierres chaudes entre hommes Salas
[Applaudissements]
le même jour
retour à la fête de la bière
[Rires]
je vais voir où tu habites il va falloir
que je le range
un petit dîner aussi avec moi
très bien allez c'est bon je vais faire
la semaine de la galère le train
le 13 village le 13 c'est noté
13 Béatrice alors moi j'aimerais bien
une semaine dans une de vos maisons en
vacances avec moi si vous êtes en bonus
pourquoi pas mais euh
je reconnais c'est gênant mais en fait
non mais parce que vous avez des des
maisons
s'il te plaît
[Musique]
dans les pièges elle me dégoûte c'est
pas possible pour le bête j'ai pas de
retour
[Musique]
on l'appelle toi l'américaine tu vas
déçu tu m'as déçu l'américaine ah moi je
rêve d'un truc quoi je sais pas si c'est
possible
non non parce que vous êtes trop fort
j'aimerais vraiment que vous m'offriez
une semaine de stage chez Morad UGlu à
l'Académie Morat Togo
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu peux m'envoyer le numéro
de Patrick moratoon je vais l'appeler en
direct c'est un truc entraîneur du monde
en tout cas
personnalité
moi j'attends le cadeau de Jean-Marie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'idéal ça serait le Maroc qui passe le
Sénégal
[Rires]
[Musique]
France en quart de finale peut-être
que vous iriez choisir avec Fatou parce
que elle m'engueule tous les jours en
disant tu prendrais le risque que
j'aille passer une journée
méfie-toi de ton père
tu es sûr tu veux pas venir je préfère
la surprise alors tu veux donc je vais
amener Fatou je vais venir chercher
Fatou voiture
et là je passe la journée avec toi c'est
un manteau et après je ramène à la
maison tu crois qu'elle va vouloir
revenir maison à quelle maison à la
mienne oui et tu penses vraiment que le
soir quand tu vas rentrer elle va dire
ma vie n'est pas une vie de merde
vous êtes très nombreux
c'est incroyable je vais le faire oh
génial je vais pas te rendre
[Rires]
j'appelle Patrick Moreau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah bah du coup j'avais pas compris
[Applaudissements]
à manger dans sa gamelle
en parlant de gamelle quand est-ce que
c'est la gamelle alors c'est à dire
Mathieu tu peux lui parler
dans un quart d'heure
heureusement
pour Patrick mon Patrick comment ça va
c'est le plus grand entraîneur du monde
je le dis mais Patrick ça va mon chéri
d'amour je suis à l'antenne en direct
tu connais Géraldine maillet
c'est de faire un stage dans ton
académie je voudrais l'offrir est-ce que
c'est possible
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr que je viens bientôt
il y a que toi qui peut me remettre au
titre il y a que toi qui peut me
remettre au nez il y a que toi je t'aime
fort je t'aime fort tu es une bombe mon
Patrick continue je t'embrasse très fort
c'est le best c'est le best le meilleur
c'est bon c'est pour moi
je suis toutes ces vidéos sur insta
c'est extraordinaire
c'est pas sûr que j'y arrive j'ai 7 ans
tu m'entends mais c'est une belle
histoire le Père Noël pour moi et ça
commence à sentir un peu la merde tu
vois je commence à avoir un peu des
vieux doutes et mon père c'est ce qui
fait le matin je descends et dis-toi je
dis mais tu es sûr que c'est le Père
Noël qui amené les cadeaux mais qui bien
sûr il est arrivé en pleine nuit il
faisait tellement froid que papa lui a
offert un petit verre de goutte il avait
posé deux verres de gouttes sur la table
et tu vois ça c'était mon verre et ça
c'est le vert du Père Noël je te jure je
suis passé toute la matinée
j'avais le vert du Père Noël il avait bu
dedans tu vois et du coup avec ces
conneries je suis reparti pour un an
jusqu'à 8 ans j'ai cru dire comme faire
je dis pas la déception après tu vois
sinon pour les cadeaux tu vas dans une
grande surface tu vas
[Applaudissements]
toi tu donnes ta carte infinie tu vois
et là tu donnes ta carte si tu dis voilà
je donne cette carte étoile jolie paquet
cadeau avec une jolie carte dedans et tu
le donnes à celle que tu veux et elle a
un bon d'achat de 3000 balles par
exemple ou 5000
[Applaudissements]